ladies and gentlemen the london real
organization has now
attacked the group of young journalists
some of them are 15 years old
who beat him so bad in an interview that
he ran away early
now london real has issued a statement
calling them disingenuous
saying that the fault was not with brian
it's with them
forget this brian doesn't have the
receipts
the kids do the kids like tracked the
whole thing
and now are exposing him live again
for going back up against them it's
incredible he just keeps digging or as
uh my buddy david fuller would say rebel
wisdom he's
the grift that keeps grifting so i know
it's another emergency broadcast y'all
are sick of hearing about brian but oh
boy
hey this is the this is the best
entertainment i get all year
okay i'm gonna be streaming the election
guys very soon as well you should know
that it's coming right up
but man i mean are you guys not
entertained brian rose is now
attacking kids let's take a look
together
shall we okay oh my gosh
oh you gotta look at this check it out
guys this is from left foot forward i
guess a publication in england i guess
rose's spokesman said that the young
journalists were being
disingenuous can we show that clip of
where brian was getting destroyed real
quick
20 minutes so we're just after the hour
so howard's just giving me a shake here
firstly brian didn't cut short the video
wow
he made time to talk to politics relaxed
on a busy day
and they rocked up late for their zoom
it's the young journalists fault they're
irresponsible
kids that's what brian rose's
organization is saying
a bunch of twerpy kids causing trouble
right pay attention to that the guys ask
challenging questions and it would be
good if more candidates were prepared to
submit to a grilling like this
so they're going hey we had to submit to
the 15 year olds
everyone should have to we got so
destroyed
oh my gosh but it's disingenuous to
complain about the time they had
when it was them who messed up their
timekeeping okay so check this out so
the guy brian rose is basically saying
these twerpy kids
he's accusing these kids of lying of
lying ladies and gentlemen he's accusing
them of not being
real journalists being unprofessional
rocking up late
but guess who has the receipts not brian
it's this guy this kid his name's felix
he's a lovely guy i chatted with him
here's the email between him and brian's
team
great brian might want to record on his
zoo blink either way
5 10 to 5 45 p.m
confirmed so it's supposed to go to 545
and this kid is here
with the time being 5 33 that's when
brian left
the zoom call the kid had the
wherewithal
to show the time this kid is a genius
dude
brian went up against a kid journalist
who knew his stuff
and he got destroyed tried to attack him
again
now calling him disingenuous
unprofessional whatever now he's getting
destroyed again
how good is this man oh it's so
wonderful
to see a guy dig his own grave
so uh effectively now it's also worth
noting that brian
or brian's team addresses the copyright
concern
they say that the copyright concern is
just uh
them having to worry about repurposed
stuff
by unauthorized third parties i guess
they're complaining about fair use there
which is funny for a free speech org but
they apply our content id to
all recorded materials which use our
assets
eg zoom calls vlogs and the like so
brian records every zoom call he's a
part of
and uploads it as if it's his possession
which it's not by the way if i
if i go and i go on like fox news and i
zoom in
it's not that's not my content they have
the rights to publish that
and what he's saying here is that they
apply copyright to it that's not how it
works
also that's clearly not exactly true
because
brian rose also copyrighted the mail
pluses coverage of him
we'll talk about that another time but
i've gotten copyrights that have
no none of brian's content in it so this
is an objective lie
but i don't want to get in that right
now because it's distracting from the
main point the main point is
is that brian rose went up against a
bunch of kid journalists
he thought it would be an easy softball
interview
and now he's spinning it as you know
more candidates should be prepared to
submit to a grilling like this
he calls his interview a grilling
and then says that it's not his fault he
ran away
the kid screwed up that turned out to be
a lie the kids have a receipt
how does this guy have any credibility
left you're out
attacking kids you're you're attacking
kids oh man this is just
it's too rich man i don't know where it
goes here for brian but um
i don't know how anyone can watch this
and think this is professional
but either way guys just go subscribe to
the politics relaxed
channel they're doing great work and
really proud of them
they may be the ones to take down bride
like it wasn't me
it wasn't rebel wisdom it wasn't any of
us so yeah
that's basically it thanks for watching
and i'll see you in the next one